j'accueille maintenant victoire
patouillard
victoire patouillard bonsoir vous êtes
militantes d'act up depuis 1994 et
présidente depuis 2001 mais comme c'est
une activité évidemment qu'il ne vous
rapporte pas d'argent bénévoles donc
vous êtes prof dans un lycée
alors avant d'entamer la discussion
j'aimerais que vous me disiez quels sont
les objectifs d'act up
act up c'est une association de
personnes séropositives donc le but de
l'association c'est de lutter contre le
sida et de lutter aussi contre tout ce
qui contribue à la propagation
d'épidémies
d'accord alors acteur intervient à
travers ce que vous appelez entre vous
des des apps c'est à dire des
interventions médiatiques vous faire
remarquer il ya eu ici sur ce plateau il
ya quinze jours
azap parce que j'avais reçu plusieurs
fois d'ailleurs c'est vrai denrées
droite rive gauche d'attribuer sur ce
plateau un garçon qui s'appelle érik
rémès et on va voir de quoi il s'agit le
manitoba
qu'est ce qu'un berbère coeur alors
barbe à coeur c'est une personne
séropositive qui désirent avoir des
rapports sexuels non protégés avec
d'autres barback heures avec d'autres
personnes séropositives
il ya aussi une forme plus radicale qui
le bar bakker qui veut contaminer les
personnes séronégatives voilà et ben moi
j'ai voulu un petit peu traitée tout
tout ce problème là par exemple qu'on
vous dit
alors vous pouvez dire que c'est le
personnage du roman et je sais pas vous
mais quand vous infecter sciemment un
garçon qui s'appelle pierre sous
prétexte qu'il est con et prétentieux et
que vous rajouter c'est un service à lui
rendre pour donner un sens à la vie
je suis quand même en excuse moi c'est
un crime de détraqués il ya pas y'a pas
d'autres mots c'est la jouer les
moralistes mais c'est un crime c'est un
roman oui il a marqué roman quia marché
romand est tout à fait donc je dis pas
que j'ai fait j'ai pratiqué ces choses
là je mets expression il ya beaucoup de
gens éventuellement que j'aurais
contaminée qui auraient été contaminés
ailleurs de toute façon à taratata
tu as passé
voilà
il encore
on sait qu'aux appareils d'exonérer
hahaha
bien ça y est tout le monde est calme
mais bon une fois ça vous concerne pas
mon cher que de mal
c'était un acte noble voilà donc ça
c'était sur le plateau de tout le monde
en parle il ya quinze jours
effectivement sur le moment j'ai compris
que c'était act up mais j'avais pas du
tout réalisé que c'était en liaison avec
l'invitation de érik rémès dont qui sait
pas qui soutient enfin qui fait la
propagande du barebacking si vous aviez
voulu le savoir vous pouviez demander
j'aurais pu vous le dire mais moins cher
moi justement j'aime pas qu'on débarque
sur mon plateau sans me prévenir
pourquoi alors je vous pose la question
très simplement et victoire pourquoi ne
pas m'avoir appelé trois jours avant dix
ans écoutait ardisson vous invitez ms
nous ça nous plaît pas du tout on veut
pouvoir venir le dire sur votre plateau
vous savez bien qu'ici on reçoit des
gens qui ont des avis extrêmement
différent vous savez bien reçoit goupil
en reçoit de la baie et dieudonné
alors pourquoi ne pas m'avoir appelé
avant je crois que les gens ont compris
avec l'extrait que vous avez passé le
bareback c'est donc un discours qui fait
l'apologie des pratiques à risque et qui
appelle à la contamination
c'est ça le bareback donc évidemment
nous en tant qu'association lutte contre
le sida lutter contre le bareback c'est
un de nos objectifs
à partir de ce moment là effectivement
on fait tout pour que ce discours soit
le moins diffusés possible avant que ray
mais soit invitée dans l'émission tribu
on a eu toute la production de votre
émission leur a demandé de ne pas
inviter des écrivains berbère cup et
vous les avez invité tout donc là ce
qu'on veut nous c'est pas c'est pas
passé à la télé c'est pas ça notre
objectif parce que ça va pas annuler une
fois que érik rémès a été invité une
fois qu'il a pu effectivement vendre son
livre les faits et là est la question qu
on veut plein le problème qu'on veut
poser ses problèmes de votre
responsabilité à vous parce que c'est
vous qui choisissez de l'été c'est vous
qui choisissez tout à fait ce type de
discours
vous savez les conséquences et vous
savez que ça va avoir des conséquences
en matière de contamination donc à ceux
partir de ce moment là la question c'est
la question de votre responsabilité
je vais vous répondre moi je trouve que
dans cette émission on montre des choses
qui existent mais ne se remet pas
toujours d'accord avec ces choses et je
pense que montrer des gens qui
pratiquent le barebacking c'est à dire
des séropositives qui baisent sans
capote pour être clair je pense que le
fait de dire que ça existe c'est une
fonction prophylactique
c'est à dire que ça dit aux gens mettez
la capote encore plus qu'avant parce que
maintenant il ya des cinglés vous êtes
bien mais j'ai dit détraqué il ya des
cinglés des détraqués qui baisse sans
capote donc les mecs comme ça pour moi
le fait de le montrer
je vous dis franchement je cherche pas à
me disculper je dis franchement le fait
de montrer des becker pour moi c'est une
façon de dire méfiez-vous encore plus
voilà et vous vous dites c'est votre
avis je le respecte
vous dites non il faut pas les montrer
du tout ce que je vous dis c'est que
voulait montrer systématiquement c'est à
dire que guillaume dustan qui est un
autre écrivain baker vous l'avait invité
à chaque fois qu'il a sorti un livre
éric n'avait pas besoin d'appeler aussi
simplement il a dit sur votre plateau
meurt plus du sida ce qui est un
mensonge évidemment personne ne l'a
repris donc à ce moment là effectivement
érik rémès sort un livre personnes non
pas dans la presse mais vous vous
l'invitez trois fois savez pourquoi les
livres dont on parle pas c'est cela dont
je vais parler c'est pour ça que ma
blessure ce plateau ce soir c'est pour
ça que plein de gens sur ce bateau je
pense que la démocratie c'est que tout
le monde puisse parler mais seulement il
ya plusieurs manières effectivement de
faire état du bareback et le livre des
récrés mais s'il s'agit pas c'est pas un
reportage s'est pas présenté un état des
lieux dire ça le bareback voilà ça
existe non c'est appeler à la
contamination notamment à la
contamination des militants d'être paris
par exemple et c'est faire la promotion
des pratiques à risque est ce que vous
avez lu ce livre
oui alors je peux vous lire un passage
vous dit simplement ce que vous en
pensez d'accord alors pour plomber
quelqu'un je précise plombé ça veut dire
contaminée pour tomber quelqu'un c'est
également très simple il suffit d'un peu
de doigté de patience et de subterfuges
on retire discrètement la capote pendant
la belle on fait semblant de la m des
plongeurs crève préalablement les
capotes avec une aiguille d'autres les
sortes de l'emballage et des couples
réservoir il la remette ensuite
ensuite on à la description très très
lente et très avec beaucoup de plaisir
de la contamination d'un militant d'act
up qui se termine pas j'ai tombé un acte
piennes j'ai pompé une acte piennes
tralalala la tra la la la la
dès le lendemain la fit la mode a été
vite répandue qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
j'en pense exactement ce que je vous ai
dit c'est à dire que ça existe
apparemment et gens que j'avais parlé
avec rémès de cette idée de couper le
bout de la capote pour que le sperme
puisse passer évidemment et je trouve
que le faire je peux être complètement
court mais je trouve que le fait de dire
que ça existe ça doit inciter les gens à
mieux porter la capote voilà je suis
désolé c'est ma conviction je peux pas
vous dire le contraire mais vous
diffusez vous diffusez ce discours dont
vous refusez on a été d'avoir votre
responsabilité c'est saint laurent vous
ma responsabilité elle et de dire aux
téléspectateurs
faites gaffe il ya des cinglés qui coupe
le bout des capotes pour filer le sida à
d'autres gens je encore du noir avait
pas nous on le savait pas donc nous on
l'a découvert par votre émission ce qui
a été je pense un bon vecteur aussi pour
vous parce que le problème et ça permet
de faire une sorte de communication si
pour votre association
mais notre but c'est pas si on était
tous les marchés complètement différente
non je ne crois pas qu invité un
écrivain qui fait l'apologie des dents a
dit gary c est ça soit glorieuse pour la
liste comptant que si on regarde les
gens c'est ça la touche je pense
qu'effectivement il faut de la
prévention est expliquée effectivement
mais vous allez après ma notion quelques
mois que la prévention ça ne fera que la
prévention efficace je peux pas dire
autre chose
je crois effectivement que la
particularité de l'épidémie de sida
c'est que c'est une épidémie qui se
diffuse par des pratiques l'information
avec centrale ce qui est central c'est
diffuser la bonne information à la
d'inviter des écrivains baker comme le
fait tirer ardisson absolument
systématiquement le problème par
ailleurs c'est que c'est une émission de
service public c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui la seule manière de parler
du sida effectivement c'est d'inviter
des écrivains verbeek à ce moment là
effectivement c'est un loisir public à
voir là dedans parce que si sous
prétexte qu'on travaille dans le service
public on doit faire des émissions
consensuel c'est plus le service est
intéressant dans service public
pardon mais ce que tu as fait attendre
ce public enfin à mon sens c'est france
inter par rapport à rtl c'est france 2
bat encore à tf1 sur cette liberté qu'on
a d'inviter des gens comme dieudonné
comme nab qui sont pas politiquement
correct je pense qu'à une époque
personne voulait inviter dieudo iliaque
ici qu'ils pouvaient par les nappes
c'est pareil je pense que ms
je trouve ça dégueulasse je lui ai dit
qu'il était un détraqué mais le fait de
dire il ya des cinglés qui baise des
séropos qui baisent sans capote je pense
que c'est une démarche prophylactique
voilà donc notre jeu je m'emballe est
d'accord avec moi je dis simplement que
je ne vous méprenez pas je n'ai aucune
envie aucune envie de propager le sida
rassurez vous mais je pense qu'elle fait
je pense que si un petit scandale dans
votre émission a pour conséquence des
contaminations et ensuite des cadavres
mais que ça vous fait gagner quelques
points de dymat ce n'est pas un problème
je vous laisse la responsabilité que
c'est que cette émission fait 30% de
parts de marché régulièrement depuis des
années elle n'a pas besoin de scandale
pour continuer à réussir voilà c'est
parce que la valeur que ça que ça mais
les gens aujourd'hui ont besoin d'être
choqués pour comprendre de plus en plus
malheureusement
malheureusement quand guillaume dustan
l'addition votre plateau plateau on ne
meurt plus du sida personne ne la
contredit vous vous rendrez compte la
portée de tels propos
aujourd'hui où on sait que l'épidémie de
sida par ailleurs elle est en pleine
reprise
on sait qu'il ya toujours pas de
prévention à l'école et vous laisser ses
propos justement de la gare un rôle de
service public effectivement jeu pour la
prévention ça fait partie des missions
de service je vous ai dit ce que j'en
pensais vous dites ce que vous en pensez
clairement les yeux dans les yeux
maintenant parlons cinq minutes d'act up
c'est à dire il ya le livre
effectivement dairy crest metz il ya le
livre d'alain soral aussi auquel vous
vous en prenez et alors là je voudrais
qu'on s'explique aussi vous aller
saccager cirque act up est allé saccagé
les bureaux d'un éditeur qui s'appelle
les éditions blanches qui sont dirigés
par franquin comme vous voulez on a
collé des affiches sur les murs du monde
et d'ici vous avez vidé tous et
quand pièces issues d'un petit peu parce
que dans ma musique est une assistante a
été blessée elle a voulu empêcher une
pile de livres de tomber effectivement
elle a pris un livre à la femme est
arrêtée six jours mais les actions d'act
up
pour ceux qui ont pu en voir sont les
actions absolument non violente c'est à
dire qu'on s'en prend pas aux personnes
que moi je dis un jour je lui arriver
sur ce plateau c'était forcément violent
avec les vigiles ça a été extrêmement
violent et j'en suis vraiment j'en suis
désolé parce que c'est nous qui avons
plutôt subi les coups mais on est une
association non violence la violence
qu'on utilise et une violence symbolique
effectivement coller des affiches dans
une maison d'édition prendre des livres
sur des rayonnages et les jeter par
terre c'est une violence symbolique mais
c'est rien par rapport à la violence
qu'ils exerçaient par ces propos lors de
la deuxième action d'act up vous avez
saccagé le journal 20 ans non c'est
pareil on a collé des affiches parce que
alain soral il travaille donc c'est dire
aux gens qu'ils emploient alain soral si
vous continuez à employer à la chorale
on viendra saccagé vos bureaux jusqu'à
ce que vous l'employez plus donc c'est
une façon la seule façon de le mettre au
chômage avaient été mal informés
le journal 20 ans a été happé parce que
il y avait un article qu'il donnait
toutes les raisons de ne pas coucher
avec quelqu'un et parmi ces raisons il y
avait le fait qu'ils soient séropositifs
est ce que quelqu'un a quelque chose à
dire dieu de haut zazie c'est difficile
d'avoir un point de vue parce que c'est
vrai aussi que moi j'ai été un vendredi
zapper à tort et je suis je suis ici
j'ai une telle une tribune pour pouvoir
m'exprimer et puis expliquer mon
problème donc je pense que c'est aussi
la chance d'avoir ici un endroit où tout
le monde peut venir s'exprimer
c'est toujours délicat et en même temps
qui ne dites moi comment sa victoire
dans ses jugements
dites moi à part des néonazis des mecs
d'extrême droite des fascistes que je
recevrai jamais parce que je tiens j toi
qui je n'invite pas sur ce plateau
sérieusement dites moi quel est le le
courant de pensée qui ne sont pas
invités si c'est à dire en matière de
lutte contre le sida a parlé baker
depuis un an qui avez vous invité
c'est vrai il faut savoir une chose
c'est que déjà il lutte contre contre un
espèce de consensus atroce qui concerne
penser que le sida n'existe plus et qu
on les rattrape plus ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que c'est souvent des gens qui sont
séropositifs
au mieux c'est à dire qu'ils sont
confrontés au réel de la maladie et que
je pense que on est là confronté à tout
ce qu'il ya de différence entre le réel
et une observation de la réalité qui est
la télévision je comprends le point de
vue thierry ardisson je pense que en
effet malheureusement pour la plupart
des gens qui regardent la télévision
c'est plus parlant de voir l'aberration
de ce genre de pratique que parfois les
actes de déjean d'act up
je suis la première à trop et ça
absolument atroce on est dans un espèce
de consensus d'un cent du total
mais tant mieux si je veux dire acteur
peut être là aussi pour dire attention
le combat n'est pas dans une année
moigne âge de la réalité mais dans un
réel
question les gens comme m justement
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait parce que pour
moi c'est des criminels qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait est ce qu'ils vont en prison est
ce que ce qui sont là à visage ouvert il
vit ça comme il est une banalité mais
c'est quand même une démence total c'est
du domaine du démon de la kevin de
détraqués tutelle c'est un crime mais
seulement pour celui qui écrit celui qui
diffuse le discours c'est à dire
l'éditeur ou vous n'a aucune
responsabilité et c'est ça qui m'étonne
dans votre discours vous voulez porter
aucune responsabilité sur la cohésion
alors que sans vous le bareback
n'existerait pas c'est à dire que
médiatiquement c'est vous qui avez donné
une audience vervaeke en les invitant
système vous savez j'ai un petit louis
disiez-vous pas parler des néo nazis
parce que c'est pas bien mais s'il faut
dire que les néo net écoutez moi je vais
vous dire une chose que après après je
lui ai posé une question sur l'acte moi
je vous dire une chose ya deux théories
dans la vie il ya pas de liberté pour
les ennemis de la liberté et ja je ne
partage pas vos idées mais je suis prêt
à mourir pour que vous puissiez les
exprimer
moi je suis de la seconde catégorie
voilà je vais pas ajouter quelque chose
je vous en prie je ne veux pas profiter
de mon statut d'animateur
je discute avec vous la liberté
d'expression c'est pas je dis quelque
chose et ensuite je m'en lave les mains
donc la liberté évidemment la liberté
d'expression at t pour mais aussi la
responsabilité de ses actes et la
responsabilité de ce qu'on voit là moi
je vous dis que pour moi lutter contre
la propagation du sida ça passe aussi
par le fait de montrer des berbères
coeur vous dit non je vous dis oui tiens
on sera pas diffusé des messages de
prévention sur la réalité donc tu
viennes moment on va terminer là dessus
je voulais vous demander une simple
chose à l'époque où act up lutter par
exemple pour que les préservatifs soient
vendues moins cher pourquoi on trouve
des préservatifs partout moi j'étais un
très grand partisan d'act up
ce que je comprends moins aujourd'hui
dans l'attitude d'acteurs permettez moi
de vous le dire victoire que vous êtes
la présidente c'est quelle est votre
légitimité pour donner des leçons de
morale c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui vous
nous parlez vous calé
qui êtes vous pour nous dire ce qu'on
doit faire et pas faire est ce que le
fait d'être homosexuel de l'indrois non
ça ne m'enlève pas des droits mais ça ne
donne pas non plus alors notre
légitimité c'est que on est comme gelée
dit une association de malades on est
une association effectivement issu de la
communauté homosexuelle
on travaille maintenant depuis plus de
dix ans et je pense effectivement qu'on
a une légitimité sur la question du sida
pour et sur la question aussi de l'image
et des représentations parce qu'il faut
voir aussi le discours de la honte dont
on est sortis act up a contribué à
donner une visibilité aux malades a
donné aussi une image positive et c'est
pour ça que la question de l'image la
question des représentations on donne du
sida est une question qui est importante
et je pense c'est pas des leçons de
morale mais c'est des questions
effectivement qui sont des questions
politiques si vous voulez mais deux
politiques d'urgence vitale prend
d'accord en tout cas moi je serai un
jour ailleurs c'est que aujourd'hui tous
les deux vous me l'avez convaincu que ja
oui c'était une guerre utile de se
battre contre ce genre de torchon tuquoi
c'est comme si moi je vais dénoncer mais
pour dénoncer je vais inviter victoire
vous aviez à dire oui je souhaiterais
que vous cessiez d'inviter des écrivains
baker d'accord et je compte je crois que
le bareback s'arrêtera au moment où vous
arrêterez les enjeux responsable du
bareback en france non mais de sa
diffusion wii de son importante que sa
diffusion